alors en france
vous êtes ici pour faire des concerts et
puis un cd qui sort c'est comment on
fait non mon truc
république il ne fait pas lui je crois
pas pour eux est-ce que balladur l'a
fait bien vous avez une adolescence
plongé dans la littérature russe avec
les caractère tourmenté de la
littérature russe j'ai dit qu'on brade
rachmaninoff psychologie un peu
tortueuses de la littérature russe
et c'est pour retrouver ses sentiments
que votre premier disque déjà et a
longtemps été consacrée à rachmaninoff
oui j'aime les les nature angoissée et
c'est vrai qu'en fait c'était pour me
rapprocher pour rester dans ce monde
j'en suis venu au répertoire russe
musicale alors que beaucoup de gens
parce que c'est l inverse
l'envié le grand prix de l'académie du
disque à l'âge de 15 ans après seulement
cinq ou six ans de pratique sérieuse
c'est extraordinaire quoi vous êtes un
vrai don le don c'est un cetain un poids
parce que ça devienne responsabilités et
finalement avec le temps et on n'aurait
pas conscient tout de suite mais plus
savoir plus lourd lors des deux fils de
prof
oui vous avez une enfance plutôt
turbulente presque asocial préfériez la
compagnie des adultes à celle des gens
de votre âge oui ça a toujours été le
cas maintenant c'est maintenant c'est
presque l'inversé à merde
vous savez dans la vie ce qui concerne
le timing c'est le timing il fait chaud
vous êtes amis etc sont regardés oui j
aime beaucoup
est ce qu'elle vous a pas parlé d'un
capricorne dans vos noms non il n'a pas
parlé d'un capricorne ok ok attendez
attendez qu après qu est-ce que c'est
censé être mon ascendant sinon c'est le
bon signe à moi
vous n'avez pas parlé l'épisode est
celle ball non mais quand vous étiez
petit vous aimiez pas les enfants de
votre âge quoi ça vous a jamais plus
vous étiez un peu en révolte contre
votre génération d'une certaine façon
oui en fait je n'avais pas grand chose à
leur dire et je me sentais coupable donc
ce n'était ni la prétention ni de là
mais est ce que je remarque et surtout
chez les enfants de mon âge c'était
c'était là finalement la la cruauté et
heureusement l'âge de 8 ans j'ai
rencontré le piano coup de bol vous
dites c'est la musique qui m'a sauvé oui
de cette façon parce que c'est vrai que
j'y vais surtout dans mon imagination à
cette époque et c'est le pineau qui m'a
permis d'être enfin la musique qu'a été
ce point entre la réalité ce qui se
passait dans ma tête
heureusement parce que c'est vrai que
vous êtes quand même assez spécial comme
filles il faut dire les choses est
victime de tonnes qu'une embellie film
de toc
c'est ce que c'est les toc bravo
églantine les troubles obsessionnels du
comportement c'est bien si vous cherchez
une place de linda hardy est la
bienvenue à réaliser que ça dure pas et
c'est ça c'est ça le problème
tu as bien alors
non mais c'est vrai alors hélène grimaud
est victime de top album était grave
c'est un peu par exemple à l'âge de 6
ans quand elle saisit une blessure à la
main droite elle se fait même à la main
gauche par souci de symétrie vous dites
souvent j'ai la sensation d'être au bord
du précipice c'est vrai vous fait un
bruit à l'époque
oui mais toujours maintenant mais ça
c'est une bonne chose c'est comme ça
qu'on est toujours en vie ça vous plaise
ou non par exemple j'aimerais maintenant
je sais pas c'est toujours le cas mais
vous ranger vos vêtements vous mesuriez
15 cm pour qu'il soit bien tout se
rangeait au centimètre près c'est vrai
ça réclame à me dépasser
je suis un peu comme ça moi mais à l'âge
de 7 ans c'est vrai et puis par exemple
quand vous arrivez dans une chambre
d'hôtel et avant d'allumer la lumière
orangée tout mais moi je suis un peu
comme ça je comprends ça c'est bien
j'avais ça va en faire des coeurs il ya
un truc le pire c'est l'histoire d'une
étude avec les dauphins là c'est à dire
que s'il vous plaît ça dort c'est petit
j'adore cette piste
eh bien elle avait un pull avec des
dauphins et puis ce puel le regarder
comme ça elle se disait est ce que je
vais le mettre ce que je vais pas le
mettre
si je le mets je vais l'abîmé donc le
regarder comme ça et elle était là
n'était parce que aux soixante dix
huitième étage d'un immeuble sur l'autel
au japon elle acheté par la fenêtre et
en jetant le pull par la fenêtre et
s'est libéré de ses stocks
je vois que tout le monde annonçait
régulièrement je monte un immeuble et je
jette mais plus vous êtes libérés tout
ça maintenant je me suis libérée des
manifestations les comment dire qui ment
des esclaves
voilà j'espère que ça c est du vélo là
pour les psys levine février chez nom de
cette intervention s'était je voulais
c'était presque agréable je sais pas
comment l'expliquer je sais combien avec
les toques c'était un symptôme d'une
certaine la sécurité en même temps j'ai
toujours su de quoi j'étais capable donc
allez savoir
revisite la musique est pour beaucoup
là-dedans pas la musique vous avez
beaucoup à vos libertés non parce qu'à
l'époque du pull avec les dauphins au
japon avait déjà la musique et si oui
alors c'est pas le piano qui passe par
la fenêtre
on va continuer les études des lèvres
donc après la découverte de la musique
donc cédé au conservatoire d'aix en
provence marseille et à l'âge de 13 ans
vous êtes première au conservatoire de
musique de paris à l'unanimité du jury
c'était pour entrer ce n'était que le
début l'année pendant que c'est bien de
là vous devenu une espèce de petite star
un très médiatisée trois ans plus tard
oui ça vous a gavé ça te faire des
photos dans l'ahl avec des robes à
froufrous tout ça ça vous fatiguer non
oui ça me fatiguait mais je n'avais pas
je n'étais pas encore moi-même donc ça
prend du temps
retrouvez eric et là j'étais tout jeune
je suis d'avoir 16 ans bah oui c'est ça
ouais c'est vrai qu'après on se laisse
on se laisse manipuler et 1
mais en même temps j'ai beaucoup appris
de ça donc je suis si c'était à refaire
je le referais exactement la même façon
et c'est quand vous avez réalisé que
finalement le piano était quelque chose
d'assez et 3 par rapport à la musique et
finalement vous avez été gavés un peu de
piano comme ça pendant toutes ces années
de l'âge de 9 ans à l'âge de 15 ans mais
je me suis jamais c'était une c'est vrai
que c'était une boulimie le piano du
voile à répartir définitivement son art
je ne suis pas d'une vie pour pour
l'explorer c'était moi qui marine est là
dedans après on aurait pu me suis rendu
compte que le piano n'est qu'un
instrument qu'une voix de la musique
alors là que vous avez une espèce de
passion pour propos les grands espaces
pour les animaux vous partez en floride
à tallahassee en floride et vous
rencontrer à côté de chez vous un voisin
un vétéran du vietnam qui est un mec
était assez asocial qui n'était pas très
aimé des gens sains
il faisait peur il faisait peur tout ce
temps les gens peuvent même le détruire
alors il élevait une louve et donc vous
avez hérité de la loupe parce que lui il
voulait plus s'en occuper où il pouvait
plus s'en occuper
non je crois que lui réalisé les limites
de la fin de sa relation avec elle et je
crois que au moment où il m'a rencontré
sa nouvelle ère avec moi mais je crois
que le parc son parcours lui a fait
réaliser qu'en fait c'est ses
motivations n'étaient pas suffisantes la
changer de plus une femme après non il
mort le pauvre et ma vie ne serait pas
ce qu'elle est sans lui
et là donc parce que pour avoir une
louve pouvez pas avoir une louve comme
ça pendant une louve il faut quand même
faire un petit peu d études peut pas
élever des loups comme ça chez vous il
faut suivre des cours de comportement
animal logic est capable de contrôler
suppose deux ans d'études deux ans de
stage pour devenir éthologue c'est une
vraie différence est une vraie passion
c'est la louve par rapport une chienne
ou par rapport à un chien c'est ça
apporte quoi de plus non dans mon cas ça
n'a pas été une fascination pour
l'animal lui-même qui a fait que j'ai
voulu poursuivre bon j'ai été intrigué
par son comportement après au fur et à
mesure que j'ai découvert de plus en
plus de choses sur les loups et surtout
sur leur rôle écologique
j'ai voulu m'investir dans leur
protection ce qui est bien c'est que
quand on fait attention de travail pour
protéger les loups en fait d'une pierre
millet plus court parce qu'on protège
pour protéger le loup il faut protéger
son habitat et quand le loup est présent
dans certaines certains endroits tous
les animaux qui vivent sous le joug dans
la chaîne alimentaire sont protégés les
mêmes coûts en fait ce qu'il veut savoir
où est ce que vous savez avec les loups
donc ce jour décidé d'élever des loups
je pense pas que ça m'arrivera mais bon
on sait jamais si non le vous pouvez pas
partir longtemps par exemple
hélène bon là elle par un peu plus
normalement pouvez pas vous éloigner du
loup plus d'une dizaine de jours on ne
peut pas dire aux voisins tu es tu me
garde mon logement ça oui voilà ensuite
le look homme c'est animal sauvage vous
pouvez pas c'est ridicule de nourrir à
heure fixe
parce que le lou va se prendre pour un
chien dans que le loup faut le nourrir à
des heures un petit peu aléatoires
bon ensuite mais pas lui mettre la
viande au même endroit parce que le loup
par exemple il ya elle m'a remis la
viande au même endroit je suis pas un
chien est alors le loup ce qui est
génial avec le loup c'est qu'il n'est
pas reconnaissant c'est vrai poursuit
qui ne nourrit dire que le chien et
flèches bouffer il faut jamais tourné le
dos à un loup ah oui c'est une relation
c'est une relation très spéciale c'est
pas du tout quelqu'un qui vous renvoie
l'amour que vous lui donnez le loup est
parti en tournée ça détend
vous êtes devenu revendeur connaissez on
est six personnes nationaux copé non
mais finalement non ce n'est pas spécial
de ça de façon il faudrait que les
relations humaines soient plus comme ça
donne rien prendre pour comment dire
pour du c'est à dire banale sur motel où
il faut rester vigilant vigilance n'est
pas une mauvaise chose
vigilant ça veut dire qu'on fait plus
pour l'autre également mais c'est en me
disant ça donne jamais alors un loose
semestre si bien sûr que ça donne et si
on tourne le dos aux qui vous bouffe
c'est quand même pas une relation
amicale traître et elle me plaît non ce
n'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
le loup donne mais ne donne pas par
rapport à la nourriture qu'il a reçus il
donne dans le lien social si le lien
social la choisit donc le lien et ont
récemment réussi choisi à quel moment
quand il regrette de vous bouffer des
cargos et qui bouffent pas c'est qu'il a
choisi
non la question n'est pas de savoir
quand ils commencent à le choisir c'est
quand ils arrêtent de le vivre c'est là
qu'il faut faire attention et d'observer
les signaux que lui ne vous donnent des
maux sociaux qui sont très excités souci
déjà il vole ou des attaques ou non pas
avec pas avec ce dont je m'occupe
imaginer le reste voilà est donc en 1995
a prêté à l'as si hélène grimaud
s'installe dans le connecticut pas loin
de new york une maison avec quelques
hectares de bois où vous vivez on a vu
tout à l'heure des images avec volou
mais c'est vrai qu'après vous croyez
plus personne une fois que les hommes
nous font plus peur j'imagine non mais
les a mangés mais cet art déjà les amm
le même jour j quelque chose de plus
difficile les hommes n'ont pas toujours
inspirés mais il m'inspire beaucoup plus
maintenant est d'ailleurs curieusement
grâce au travail que nous faisons à la
fondation ça m'a rendu plus connus -
misanthrope
[Musique]
bien encore une petite interview dernier
couet lannes vous êtes prête en à bouche
abondantes et une gare on ne bouge pas
rares dans le qinghai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup dur dernier coup dur c'est
d'avoir d'avoir vu moyens des animaux
dernier coup de tête
d'avoir refusé un concert uniquement
parce que le répertoire n'était pas moi
dans mes coups de coeur
le dernier concert parce que chaque fois
dans un conseil une communication
émotionnelle qui s'établit et c'est ça
qui sauve au fait bien des coups de
poing pas encore dans les coups de folie
tweed ou des coups de foudre
la france entière est suspendu a volé la
france entière est amoureuse de vous et
veut savoir
non non non en fait le dernier coup de
foudre c'était pour une oeuvre way we
dernier coup de gueule avec la maison de
disque l'année dernière un dernier coup
de pub ici dans les coups de fil
cette nuit à qui elle clame que j'aime
dans les coudes rouge
mais coup de rouge
non je n'aime pas trop le vin un bon nom
buvez quoi vélo c'est un guy gagnon
contrôler quoi comme drogue
ma drogue c'est le cancer c'est
l'adrénaline à la peine en bourse ou
dans des coups de soleil
il ya trop longtemps ya six ans ah ouais
ouais je vais vous parler un peu au
soleil quand même bien pourquoi je n'ai
pas le temps non autant ça se prend
remarquez on a tous 24 heures dans la
journée donc c'est hypocrite non l'été
vous pourriez partir un petit peu je
peux vous accordez side merci non mais
c'est vrai dernier coup de barre le mois
dernier à paris ouais ouais ouais
incapable depuis paris vous avez des
concerts à ce moment là non je les ai
commencé sa maman vous avez aller les
émissions de télévision mais pas des
cancers dernier coup de chapeau au
prêtre de notre paroisse dans les coups
de froid
l'indifférence dans les coups de blues
moi j'ai le blues en avance oui ah bon
j'ai le blues pour tout ce qui ne s'est
pas encore produit ailleurs dans des
cobras il n'y a pas si longtemps il ya
une semaine mais pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de linars dit tu es abonné
vous mettez un pouce bleus